we have a lot of women on our staff and
we could not do the show without them so
I'd like to take just a minute to
acknowledge three of them right now the
very talented writers Laurie Kilmartin
Jesse Gasko Leah Krinsky they're right
here
as a as a feminist myself I'm an avid
champion of gender equality frankly I've
dedicated my whole life to fighting the
patriarchy on all fronts as bell hooks
once said feminism is for everybody and
never has that statement been more
trenchant in these times that I believe
that we would oh please what a blowhard
tonin thinks he's a feminist just
because he knows the words to one Sarah
McLachlan song he thinks that time of
the month refers to win Bed Bath &
Beyond coupons expire tell me about it
anything's Lena Dunham is one of Jeff
Dunham sexy lady puppets Conan is so
clueless about women whose favorite
actress is Tyler Perry right
Conan knows so little about women's
bodies he thinks the vulva is a
mid-priced family sedan yeah and he
thinks labia majora was a character from
Star Wars
Conan thinks a pap smear is something
you put on a bagel and he thinks the
g-spot is a fast food chain
the only time Conan satisfies a woman is
when he leaves the room I know
Conan's so out of touch with a modern
woman he thinks the book lean in was
about people with scoliosis you know
what I'm just glad he hasn't figured out
that all women can communicate
telepathically I know me too
I agree girls it's our little secret
you get overheads la Bamba what are you
doing in here I've been in here for
years I've seen everything
that speech one of the great
you